[Music]
oh hey come on in
welcome to m1 imac cribs this is so
exciting because as a lot of you guys
know apple introduced
seven new colors of their m1 imac and
today i am at my sister's house who is
not very tech savvy she's also a mom and
she has a house
full of rooms that need an imac makeover
so come on in
um i'm gonna shut the door first here so
that the baby and the dogs
and the imax don't try to run away
protect the imax
protect protect let's go to our first
location
you may be wondering justine hey this is
really not safe to be putting an imac
inside of a baby crib but here's the
thing
the child actually does not like to go
in here at all
so this is a great place for mommy i'm
not mommy my sister's mommy
where she can go and just have a safe
space because the child
doesn't like to come in here anyway so
this is not a playpen
for the baby it's a playpen for the imac
and i chose the yellow one for this
specific location
because i felt like it really kind of
brought out the cheeriness of the room
i opted to use the track pad here in the
play pen because
this is kind of a rugged environment so
using a mouse on sort of
this kind of blanketed texture i thought
was not the best idea
so we're going to use the track pad i
think this really looks great i think it
really ties in the entire room
and i think it really kind of just
brightens everything up a little bit so
let's look up some stocks i feel like
that's what like
a you know a day trading mom would do so
stocks are looking good
everything looks great hi maddie do you
want to come in the pen here maddie look
at this
here look here i guess this could also
be a play pen
for the dog since this is my dog and he
doesn't really like children very much
so what do you think about the stocks
everything is looking pretty good man if
you check out right here
the apple stocks it's uh it's rising
it's going up really
high everything is going great
this is a new 1080p camera it's a larger
sensor
they've increased the image processing
so it's a way a better experience
he gets it we're heading into the
kitchen
welcome to the kitchen what's great
about this little location is
first of all because the baby her name
is bryn which is actually our niece i
keep calling her the child and the baby
but
she is related she is our niece she
absolutely loves the color purple and
she can also say purple
and every time she has been walking past
the imac boxes
she's been saying apple hopefully we can
catch her saying that here in a little
bit
but this is where she eats her food a
lot of the times so not only can mom be
over here to check out recipes when
she's cooking
but she can then spin this around just
put
it taste it yum
yum has she eaten this before
because i'm not sure if she's enjoying
it put the rest of it in there
i'm capable oh that's in your arm
she's eating applesauce and salmon and
peas
i'm feeling nauseous just thinking about
that combination
feeding time is done for britney we're
gonna flip this around
so mom can maybe watch some netflix or
some apple tv
while she's probably cleaning up what do
you think that brienne would like to
watch
i think probably anything because she
hasn't been able to watch anything in
two years well this morning i saw her
watching the property brother so maybe
we'll just put on some property brothers
for her that sounds nice
my videos yeah this is your video my
hair was very blonde
she's watching property brothers doing
dishes
she's distracted actually put the
keyboard in there oh well don't do that
now that we're done in the kitchen it's
time for dinner so
i'm going to prepare myself a nice meal
welcome to the dining room imac this is
the blue imac
i chose blue for this room because she
has a lot of like darker kind of
silvery gray colors so i felt like the
blue kind of pulled out those colors
really really well and also this is kind
of my favorite one so it's sort of the
centerpiece when you first walk into the
house and you look over
this is kind of a very warm welcoming
greeting color
having a dining room imac is honestly
key for any family because
i feel like this is really going to
bring us all together we can have
discussions
over local politics and that really does
bring families together now that i'm
full from dinner
i really want to play some games but oh
you know maybe i should have a drink
first
side note i don't even drink but we're
gonna go to the bar
for the sake of this video let's just
we're gonna let's go
hey welcome to the bar this is where we
make drinks i don't drink and i actually
don't think my sister or her husband
actually drink either but they have a
bar
in their home and i thought it would be
really great to put the silver imac here
mostly because it ties in the colors of
their bar it's kind of like a nice
silvery
kind of graphite look and i thought
vodka is
sort of a very similar color that's an
alcohol
a lot of spirits and liqueurs or
whatever i don't really know much about
alcohol but
this looks like a nice drink this is why
i'm not an interior designer or a
bartender okay that's actually why i put
it over here because it matches the
millennium falcon
lego set that my sister's husband put
together let's be real
that's actually why it's here having a
bar imac will allow you to play
music to entertain all of your guests
that you're probably not going to have
over because it's still kind of cove at
times
but when they do decide to entertain
again you have entertainment
music movies apple tv
apple arcade you can also look up bar
recipes
for drinks how to make a
mojito we are going to need club soda
lime white rum fresh mint leaves
white sugar looks like they have a lot
of sutter home
and barefoot wine and i think that's
from their wedding which was a long time
ago
i think maybe bartending is not for me
let's go play some video games
so we're now in the game room this is
where my sister's husband has his gaming
consoles he's got the playstation the
xbox he also has this really incredible
lg tv that has
apple tv built into it so you would
probably be thinking there's no
real reason that you're gonna need to
put an imac here it's very valid
most people would say that this is gonna
be the game room imac
i chose the green color because i
thought it kind of really tied in the
room
with these beautiful fake plants back
here just ties everything together so
nicely
and it makes it feel like it's the
centerpiece
of the room not the consoles not the tv
it's all about the imac something else
that is very exciting
is you can connect xbox and playstation
controllers
to this imac so you'll be able to play
games on it as well you can also do if
you have an apple tv connected
to your tv somebody could be playing on
the imac and somebody could also be
playing on the tv
i didn't even think about that brain
energy big brain energy
speaking of big brain energy my brain is
exhausted and i also think that the baby
might be tired
so maybe we should go put her to sleep
now so this is the new imac
it's an m1 chip so it's super fast very
very efficient
this has touch id built into the
keyboard right here look
touch id so when you press the touch id
button it locks it
[Music]
oh now you've turned it all off look
whoop this is the orange imac i thought
i would put it in the bedroom so that it
would kind of you know be a nice wake up
oh okay here just put that on here uh
a diaper yeah put it on there i put this
on the baby
i don't know how to do that just put one
leg in
again which side is the front that's the
track pad you have the diaper i gotta
put the diaper on oh god bryn
should we google how to put on a diaper
because i'm unsure
here we go put this on are you gonna
help me do it or do i have to do
everything myself
okay here legging good girl stand up i'm
so bad at this
how's it going brynn there you go look
at her little apple shirt
that's your apple shirt i got this in
cupertino
when you were a baby i think you
actually weren't even born yet also i
just want to note that all of the places
that i've put these
imacs are incredibly and not child
friendly so
we're not actually keeping them here
this isn't a touch screen i know that
that's something that you're used to
watch this check this out here's the
trackpad watch we're going to do oh
hold on a second here we go connect the
wi-fi
um hold on a second you can't escape yet
because
oh geez oh gosh oh boy oh boy take me
down to the takedown that's a takedown
now we've moved into learning jujitsu
okay so you want to get side control
there you go there you go side control
go girl good girl good girl
well up and running away is an option
all right come on into the nursery so
you might notice that this is a very
gender neutral bedroom because they
didn't want to know the sex of the baby
before she was born so everything is
very gray and kind of very neutral
for this room i chose the pink imac
because i really wanted to kind of tie
in the color from her sheets there's a
nice little rose theme going on
and since this is a very neutral bedroom
i thought adding a little pop of color
would be
perfect with the m1 max you're able to
run iphone apps so i think maybe putting
on a nice little calming meditation
would be really great
to help put the baby to sleep i'm
feeling relaxed already
that's really nice go
sleep time for bed
the baby is now asleep because of this
incredible relaxing melody that i was
able to play for her on the m1 mac
and one day she's gonna be old enough to
actually use this and i feel like i'm
probably gonna hire her as an editor
so anyway she's asleep i think it's time
for me to go to sleep
time for bed i'm so exhausted from
setting up seven imacs and doing all of
the software updates
life is really hard when you're an
interior decorator decorating only
with new m1 imacs i chose orange for the
bedroom
because i felt like it was a very warm
welcoming color
for when you wake up like when you wake
up you want to feel invigorated and when
i think about the color orange i think
about
breakfast i think about orange juice i
think about
beautiful tropical days and that's how i
want to start my mornings
i also like to start my mornings with
the news maybe i don't like
waking up to the news unless it's good
news
you could also listen to a podcast
starting my morning off right
to the only podcast that you should be
listening to called
same brain same brain podcast special
edition spring loaded apple event roll
that
intro please wow i'm exhausted
maddie i think it's time to go to bed so
if i want to lock my computer i'm just
going to hit that
touch id key and we are going to see
come on ready
come on let's go sleep
[Music]
night night just fake it for a second
it's okay thank you guys so much for
watching this video it's really fun to
kind of figure out which rooms these
colors would go really well
in and i think that's the great part
about them is not only are you getting
an incredibly powerful computer but they
really do look beautiful in any room
don't forget to subscribe if you guys
enjoyed this video give it a thumbs up
and of course let me know which color
is your favorite
bye